the temperature of a glass of warm water
after it's put in a freezer is
represented by the following table
so we have time in minutes and then we
have the corresponding temperature at
different times in minutes
which model for c of t the temperature
of the glass of water t minutes after
it's served best fits the data so pause
the video and see which of these models
best fit the data
all right now let's work through this
let's work through this together
so
in order for it we see these choices
some of these are exponential models
some of these are linear models in order
for it to be a linear in order for a
linear model to be a good description
when you have a fixed change in time you
should have a fixed change in
temperature
if you're dealing with an exponential
model then as you have a fixed change in
time you should be changing by the same
factor so the amount you change from say
minute one to minute two or from minute
one two to minute three it's not going
to be the exact same amount but it
should be the same factor of where you
started so let's think about this
so here
our change in
our change in time is two minutes what
is the absolute change in temperature
so our absolute change in temperature is
negative what 15.7
negative 15.7
and what if we if we viewed it as a
multiplication so what do we multiply 80
by to get 64.3
well i can
get a calculator out for that so
64.3
divided by
is equal to
0.8 i'll just say approximately 0.8 so
we could multiply by
point
zero point eight this is going to be
approximate so to get from 80 to 64.3 i
could either subtract by 15.7 if i'm
dealing with a linear model or i can
multiply by
0.8
now if i increase my time again by 2 i'm
going from minute 2 to minute 4
so delta t is equal to 2.
the absolute change here is what this is
going to be
not 12
this is going to be
my brain isn't functioning optimally if
this was 64.7
then this would be 12 but it's 4 less
than that so it's 11.6 negative
11.6 but if you look at it as
multiplying it by a factor what would
you have to multiply it by approximately
let's get the calculator back out so if
i said 52.7
divided by 64.3 divided by 64.3
is equal to about 0.82
so times 0.82
so just by looking at this i could keep
going but it looks like for a given
change in time
my absolute change in the number is not
going it's not even close to being the
same if this was like 15.6 i'd be like
okay there's a little bit of error here
data that you're collecting the real
world is never going to be perfect these
are models that try to get close to
describing the data but over here we
keep multiplying it by a factor of
roughly
0.8 roughly 0.8 now you might be tempted
to immediately say okay well that means
that c of t is going to be equal to our
initial temperature 80
times a common ratio of 0.8
to
the number of minutes that passed by now
this was very tempting and it would be
the case if this was one minute and if
this was two minutes but our change in
temperature each time is our change in
temperature each time is two minutes so
what we really should say is this is one
way to think about it is it takes it
takes two minutes to have a 0.8 change
so
or to be multiplied by 0.8 so the real
way to describe this would be t
over two every two minutes
when t is zero we'd be at eighty after
two minutes we would take 80 times 0.8
which is what we got over here after
four minutes it would be 80 times 0.8
squared in fact actually let's just
verify that we feel pretty good about
this
so
if we had something like this
t
and
c of t
so when t is 0 c of t is 80. when t is
well let me just do the same data that
we have here when t is 2
we have 80
times 2 over 2 is 1. so it's 80 times
0.8 which is pretty close to what we
have over here when t is 4 it would be
80.0.8
squared which is pretty close to what we
have right over here i can just
calculate it for you
if i have
.8 squared
times
51.2 getting pretty close this is a
pretty good approximation pretty good
model
so
i'm liking i'm liking this model this
isn't exactly one of the choices
so how do we manipulate this a little
bit well we can remind ourselves that
this is the same thing as 80
times
0.8 to the one-half and then that
to the t power and what's point eight to
the one-half
so
.8 the same thing with the square root
of 0.8 it's roughly
0.89 so this is approximately
80 times 0.89
to the t power and if you look at all of
these choices this one is pretty close
to this
this this model
best fits the data especially of the
choices going this is pretty close to
the model that i just thought about
now another way of doing it it might
have been a little bit simpler i like to
do it this way because even if i didn't
have choices we would have gotten to
something reasonable another way to do
it is say okay 80 is our initial state
all of these whether you're talking
about exponential or linear models start
with 80 when t is equal to 0 but it's
clearly not a linear model because we're
not changing by even roughly the same
amount every time but it looks like
every 2 minutes we're changing by a
factor of 0.8 so we're going to have an
exponential model so you say okay it'd
be one of these
two choices
now this one down here you could rule
out because we're not changing by a
factor of 0.8 or 0.81 every minute we're
changing by a factor of 0.81 every two
minutes so you could have ruled that one
out and then you could have deduced this
right over here and you could say look
if i'm changing by a factor of 0.9 every
minute then that would be 0.81 every 2
minutes which is pretty close to what
we're seeing here changing by a factor
of about 0.8 or 0.81 every two minutes
so once again that's why we like that
first choice